[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le journal
de tv 78 26 minutes pour faire le tour
de l'actualité locale et régionale tout
de suite les titres de ce mardi 29
octobre
c'est un rendez vous gourmand le salon
du chocolat s'ouvre à paris pour la
soirée de lancement une robe en chocolat
sera présentée tout à l'heure lors d'un
défilé elle a été façonné par plusieurs
artisans dont christophe bertrand maître
chocolatier à la reine astrid basés
notamment dans les yvelines
le procureur de la cour de cassation à
l'université versailles saint quentin
françois molins ans assistait à la
rentrée solennelle de la faculté de
droit et de sciences politiques
événement traditionnel pour lequel il
était le parrain cette année
et puis nous suivrons des adultes en
reconversion professionnelle il
participe actuellement une formation au
chapeau tremblay sur mauldre
apprentissage des métiers de
l'horticulture de l'élagage au
bûcheronnage en passant par le
maraîchage et puis à la proche d'al oui
nous parlerons de cet événement sportif
et pourquoi pas à déguiser le trio win
qui revient ce vendredi c'est aux
clayes-sous-bois aimé direction tout de
suite paris où s'ouvre ce soir
officiellement le salon du chocolat
c'est jusqu'à dimanche au parc des
expositions porte de versailles marylène
iapichino bonsoir vous êtes sur place
une robe en chocolat
elle va justement des filets ce soir
elle a été façonnée notamment par un
maître chocolatier qui est basée dans
les yvelines
mais bon ça à grégori g semaine dans les
coulisses de ce défilé du 25e salon du
chocolat à une 30ème d'europe vont être
représentés tous ces quelques heures et
parmi elles la vote christophe perton
alors est ce qu'elle est prête cette
robe
oui larvée pâle parce qu'elle a été
exposée déjà au grand palais à
l'occasion justement du 25e anniversaire
elle est prête pas content on l'a pas
encore fait essayer à la personne qui va
la porter et notamment il n'y a pas que
une robe il ya aussi tout un maquillage
qui va venir autour et notamment avec de
la dorure à leur fin qui va parcourir la
jambe de elizabeth tchoungui qui va
l'apporter donc on espère que tout ça va
fonctionner ensemble et compris avec la
chanteuse qui va accompagner cette
petite partie de défiler sur la
thématique du cameroun bien entendu
justement voulait revenir sur cette
thématique le cameroun pourquoi le
cameroun parce qu en fait
en 2017 il ya une femme qui s'appelle
aristide qui trouvait qu avec la reine
astrid y avait quelque chose de
proximité qui m'avait contacté voilà je
lui devais un voyage au cameroun et
c'est comme ça qu'elle est une histoire
assez incroyable qui fait qu'on a
vraiment fait sortir le cameroun de
l'anonymat en faisant de la fermentation
du cacao c'est un peu technique mais
c'est ça qui va valoriser donné ses
lettres de noblesse au chocolat et c'est
pour ça qu'on a voulu faire tout autour
du cameroun y compris sur notre stand
mais également ce soir
elizabeth tchoungui étant franco
camerounaise vous faites le oui c'est la
première fois qu'on défi on a pas qu on
a même de rob dyer qui vont défiler et
la première étant vraiment celle pour
laquelle on a mis le plus attention
puisqu'elle est tournée sur le cameroun
que la musique qui va l'accompagner pour
du cameroun et que finalement on a même
inspiré les organisateurs du salon du
chocolat qui ont décidé que cette année
suite à la proposition que je l'aurais
fait il ya plusieurs mois ils ont décidé
de faire à défiler sur la thématique des
pays producteurs même inspiré la
thématique de ce défilé nous consulte
ses plusieurs jours de salon de chocolat
qu'est ce qui va se passer pour vous
avez un stand alors on a un stand et
puis moi je j'ai aussi avec le conseil
départemental des hauts-de-seine
initiée en 2010 le cacao d'haïti
finalement ce que j'ai fait au cameroun
on l'avait fait avec le pense et
départementales sur la totalité de
d'haïti donc j'anime aussi en partie le
stand haïti voilà on va essayer doux de
vendre essentiellement du chocolat du
cameroun et on a réussi à faire venir
aristide la présidente de la coopérative
qui est sur notre stand pendant les cinq
jours et qui découvre la france pour la
première fois qu'ils voyagent d'ailleurs
pour la première fois de sa vie
merci chris toit pour vous souhaite un
bon salon ce salon qui se tient jusqu'au
3 novembre 230 exposants sont retrouvés
porte de versailles merci à vous marier
nous on trouvera d'ailleurs dans
l'édition de demain du 7-8 journal un
reportage sur votre escapade gourmande
au salon du chocolat avec vos à vos
côtés manou varaldo pour les moyens
techniques
dans l'actualité du jour également
le début des travaux de restauration de
la villa viardot c'est à bougival le
maire la fondation du patrimoine et
différents partenaires financiers ont
donné cet après midi les premiers coups
de pioche au chantier ce monument du 19e
siècle en péril a reçu 500 mille euros
du loto du patrimoine pour mener ces
travaux évalués en tout à 3 millions
d'euros et les particuliers entreprises
peuvent encore aider le projet en
faisant un don sur le site de la
fondation du patrimoine
une autre opération sauvons nos
monuments se donne l'objectif aussi de
sauvegarder les patrimoines en danger
initiatives de nos confrères du parisien
et de la start-up d'artagnan on connaît
désormais les 18 sites présélectionnés
après une phase d'appel à projets de son
dans les yvelines vous voyez la demeure
de villégiature vous l'avez vue datant
de 1864 à andrésy à la maison du moussel
ses murs se fissurent l'accès est
interdit au public la municipalité et
les propriétaires souhaitent en faire un
lieu d'animation culturelle puis vous
avez vu quelques photos également à d'un
autre monument c'est le prieuré des
moulineaux c'est à poigny la forêt un
vestige du 12e siècle de l'ordre des
grands mon teint qui a possédé jusqu'à
150 abbaye en france et en angleterre
il s'est transformé ensuite au xvième
siècle et il ne reste aujourd'hui que la
partie centrale de l'église la toiture y
est à refaire intégralement à noter que
sur les 18 sites retenus 9 bénéficieront
d'une campagne de financement
participatif une opération finalement en
complément du loto du patrimoine comme
le précise le site de la start-up d'arte
d'artagnan et qui était notre invité en
septembre dernier
c'est tout à fait complémentaires le
loto du patrimoine c'est une très belle
visibilité pour cette cause et cette
cause nationale qui est la préservation
du patrimoine est effectivement avec vos
confrères du parisien et la région ile
de france aussi qui va apporter une aide
financière aux projets qui seront
sélectionnés sur tout le territoire
francilien plus le département de l'oise
et bien finalement on va permettre à des
monuments et brad de récolter des fonds
auprès de la communauté d'artagnan des
lecteurs du parisien et une subvention
de la région ile de france
et qu'est-ce qui a la clé concrètement
pour le vainqueur pour l'heure un coeur
il ya plusieurs choses
il ya bien sûr une couverture médiatique
importante de la part du
du parisien que ce soit dans les
éditions départementales et nationales
il ya un accompagnement de d'artagnan
pour aider le porteur de projet à monter
une opération de financement
participatif donc on à la fois sur la
partie financement et communication et
la région ile de france peut apporter un
complément de financement qui peut quand
même aller jusqu'à 300 mille euros par
projet à condition bien sûr que le
propos étonnants engage aussi des
travaux donc finalement il a tout à
gagner se faire connaître avoir des sous
pour se développer
et puis et puis je pense que sympathique
aussi d'avoir la l'approbation du public
est en tout cas sur son territoire et
c'est à vous de désigner les 9
vainqueurs de cette première opération
sauvons nos monuments le vote est ouvert
en ligne jusqu'au 4 novembre
[Musique]
c'est un rendez vous traditionnel de la
faculté de droit et de science politique
de l'université versailles saint quentin
la rentrée solennelle s'est tenue en fin
de semaine dernière elle a rassemblé
tous les professeurs et aussi quelques
2500 étudiants
cette année l'événement a été parrainé
par le procureur de la cour de cassation
françois molins ce nicolas landry pour
un retour sur l'événement c'est le
visage de l'institution judiciaire face
aux attentats terroristes françois
molins ancien procureur de paris
aujourd'hui procureur général à la cour
de cassation le parrain cette année de
la rentrée solennelle de la faculté de
droit et de sciences politiques de l'ue
vs qu objectifs de son déplacement faire
le lien entre l'université et
l'institution judiciaire puis partager
son expérience
c'est vrai que dans le cadre une affaire
terroriste il ya un besoin
particulièrement fort et
particulièrement pressante de la part de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens que
quelqu'un vienne effectivement expliquer
ce qui s'est passé et puis se dire les
choses en les nommant et en expliquant
ce qui s'est passé de façon plus
objective possible sans porter de
jugement de valeur et en donnant tous
les éléments possibles sur le sur l'état
des investigations respect du code de
procédure pénale de l'éthique et de la
déontologie juridique des principes
enseignés à lui vs cul pour la rentrée
solennelle tous les étudiants sont
rassemblées pour honorer les quelques 50
major de chaque promotion
ça représente la concrétisation de
de mes trois années de licence et enfin
j'ai enfin réussi à
monter les grades et
voilà la récompense de tout le travail
fourni c'est en tout cas valoriser
l'excellence au sein de l'université
c'est notre recherche la particularité
de l'université c'est d'adosser la
formation de nos étudiants à la
recherche puisque le seul enseignant
chercheur et c'est cela qui assure la
qualité des enseignements que nous
dispensons plusieurs disciplines sont
proposées à lui vs qu entre droit privé
droit public un parcours international
ou encore une filière de sciences
politiques d enseignement juridique est
essentielle pour former les futurs
juristes
alors ce pote du droit pénal on pense
souvent à lui en premier mais c'est pas
que du droit pénal il ya toute une
dimension de droit privé à travers du
droit civil droit commercial du droit
social
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
renvoie à l'étendue de toutes les
connaissances qu'on peut acquérir quand
on vient dans une université comme un
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
près de 2500 étudiants sont inscrits
cette année à la faculté de droit et de
sciences politiques à lui est ce qu un
effectif en constante augmentation
chaque année toujours à saint quentin en
yvelines un campus des métiers de
l'automobile et de la mobilité a ouvert
ses portes il y a un nom à guyancourt
des jeunes y suivent des formations dans
différents organismes des formations qui
sont en apprentissage nicolas landry a
suivi à l'un d'entre eux reportages
pendant ses cours en atelier mais aussi
en entreprise regarder dès que les
coudes et de clé à cliquet et des clés
spécifiques les bronches voilà une
partie des outils de travail d'antoine
martinez ce jeune yvelinois est apprenti
en mécanique automobile
une semaine sur deux ils travaillent
dans ce garage en alternance avec sa
formation au programme de sa matinée la
révision d'une voiture accompagné par
son maître d'apprentissage elle vraiment
à le ton juste en face le trou de la
bobine il a fait la vidange juste avant
la haie
du coup on a remis le rhône a remis le
bouchon pour ce docteur antoine martinez
suit sa troisième année de formation il
passe actuellement son bac pro
maintenance des véhicules en entreprise
il acquiert le savoir-faire le gérant de
ce garage lui transmet aussi les normes
de sécurité de qualité et le soin des
véhicules du client pour mettre des
housses dans la voiture soit plus propre
depuis 11 ans cyril martinez dirige ce
garage il accueille souvent des
apprentis pour les former et les
embauches et ensuite un avantage non
négligeable pour ce chef d'entreprise
en fait il est formé un peu un peu à
notre manière un peu comme on a envie
que de devoir travailler en mécanicien
chez nous et point positif c'est que
déjà on peut alterner on peut être un
entre deux semaines on est payé on est
payé comme un comme un salarié on a des
zones et des des salaires fixes pour
pour les apprentis
quand il n'est pas en entreprise antoine
martinez dans son centre de formation
d'apprentissage la fort pas situé sur le
campus automobile de guyancourt ce
matin-là il a cours en atelier sur des
véhicules
objectif réaliser des diagnostics ont
créé des pannes sur les voitures et par
rapport à ces pannes
on donne aux jeunes comme si on était on
se transforme ce ce jour-là en clients
entre guillemets pour le jeune en disant
ma voiture à tel problème et le jeune
recherche savane
au fur à mesure des procédures et on le
guide j'ai trouvé la femme déjà
printemps
pas grand chose c'était quoi la première
fois
c'était un flic été coupée entre l'a1
entre la sonde et calculateur on apprend
à utiliser des outils qu'on n'a pas
forcément en entreprise
on apprend à utiliser suffit gym
trimestre ce qui est exhaustive à ce
qu'offre en 2019 la fort pas écueil 213
apprentis allant du cp au bac et bts
entre les cours classiques et les
activités en atelier l'objectif est
d'acquérir des compétences théoriques et
pratiques
l'apprentissage a est une est un format
de formation qui est très parlant avec
une insertion professionnelle assez
importante de l'ordre de 80 70 à 80%
un jeune en fait sortant du centre de
formation
obtient un travail dans les six premiers
mois alors je vois en toi de martinez va
poursuivre sa formation jusqu'à la fin
de l'année et un examen final son projet
professionnel à terme ouvrir son garage
ou devenir mécanicien pour le sport
automobile et après des études et
plusieurs années dans un secteur
certains optent pour un changement un
changement de voie une reconversion
professionnelle au tremblay sur mauldre
le centre horticole d'enseignement et de
promotion propose des formations pour
les adultes de l'agriculture aux
chantiers forestiers pour travailler
dans l'élagage le bûcheronnage ou encore
le maraîchage mathilde et demi ils ont
décidé de changer de profession pour
travailler dans le domaine de
l'agriculture ou dans les chantiers
forestiers une reconversion
professionnelle pour florian ancien
ingénieur qui a décidé de faire la
formation maraîchage je pense que c'est
une filière d'avenir pour tout ce qui
touche aux enjeux aux enjeux du xxième
siècle tout ce qui touche à
l'environnement à l'agriculture pour
essayer de trouver des solutions à
l'avenir pour une oeuvre cultures
pérennes pour cette formation il faut
pratiquer pour apprendre dans la serre
de production morgan formatrice en
maraîchage apprend à rempoter du persil
à anna et florian dans cette serre on a
laissé la serre de production donc du
coup on va produire tous les végétaux on
vient quatre heures en tp donc du coup
ils ont des choses à faire que je leur
donne le matin à faire et ensuite tout
simplement il éxécuté il me demande
lorsqu'ils ne comprennent pas dans les
21 et art du centre horticole
on trouve aussi la filière bois après
plusieurs blessures causées par son
ancienne profession d'orient ans un
danseur professionnel a décidé de se
reconvertir
je suis venu en formation ici en fait
parce que de base je cherchais à devenir
élagueurs et il faut maintenant un
diplôme de niveau iv délivré par le
ministère de l'agriculture
donc la formation ne permettait d'abord
une équivalence et
et c'était en rapport avec avec ce même
avec le métier d'élagueur donc je
commençais à prendre l'apprentissage
abus au à la tronçonneuse
aux métiers du bois en général une
formation qui dure neuf mois avec des
stages à effectuer pour posséder toutes
les connaissances et les appliquer sur
le terrain sans danger ça va commencer
en début de formation par des petites
interventions plutôt de l'observation et
puis petit à petit vont prendre la main
donc ils vont porter la machine non
comme machine on va avoir de la
tronçonneuse pour tout ce qui est en
entretien des arbres abattage soin des
arbres un apprentissage rapide et une
prise en charge par la région pour
décrocher le diplôme et pouvoir se
reconvertir il avait fait sensation en
clôture du dernier festival de cannes
hors norme est dans les salles depuis
une semaine une plongée dans la réalité
difficile des associations qui
accueillent des personnes autistes
qu'aux réalisations signées par olivier
nakache et eric toledano le versailles
était de passage le week-end dernier
dans sa ville natale au cinéma le cyrano
pour présenter son film il était
l'invité est de véronique ithurbide dans
le dernier vais y paie manon varaldo à
la caméra cyrano j'ai fait mes armes gp
dans la salle pour présenter avant de
faire une rencontre et j'ai toujours
plaisir à voir en plus je sais qu'il va
y avoir un grand chamboulement ici
puisqu'il a fermé qui vont refaire donc
c'est bien gérard une dernière fois le
cinéma de mon enfance qui soit
remaquiller oui et est-ce que c'est ici
que vous
nourrir votre passion du cinéma oui
sûrement j'ai vraiment usé les ici
toutes les salles en eau la grande salle
les petites salles qui sont retour j'ai
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup fréquenté
cinéma c'est le cinéma de mon enfance et
j'ai un petit relations d'affaires
parquet hier on va vous êtes parti akel
à gérer mes parents sont restés moi je
suis parti à peu près après le bac mais
mes parents et en rester là
j'avais une chambre de bonne à paille
mais je ne serai pas beaucoup à payet
j'avais beaucoup à versailles jusqu'à 25
ans dans le silence était c'était
toujours ici que ça se passe c'était le
cinéma
oui absolument désormais bien sûr du
toit alors voit pas l'énorme on est là
pour ça que le film qui servent bien
sortir là on est en projection spéciale
votre film réalisé comme d'habitude avec
votre binôme d'olivier nakache 80 voilà
on le résume en quelques mots vous
faites je veux faire qu'on
c'est comme vous voulez bah c'est un
film qui raconte l'histoire de deux
j'encadre ans on va dire deux patrons
d'associations qui s'occupent des
enfants autistes qu'on appelle des cas
sévères c'est à dire des cas qui n'ont
aucune place dans aucune institution
c'est une histoire vraie qui est
l'histoire de deux personnes qu'on
fréquente depuis une vingtaine d'années
avec olivier et qui voit là ont décidé
en dehors des règles puisqu'ils ne sont
pas complètement aux normes ils n'ont
pas d'agrément du ministère de la santé
s'occupe des cas dont personne ne veut
et pour ce il engage des jeunes des
quartiers difficiles qui sont peu qu'ils
ont un peu des parcours accidentés ça ne
fait non plus personne ne veut non plus
il y avait un vrai sujet sur justement
de deux forces
on pourrait penser négative ou en tout
cas de personnes qui sont en situation
un peu de faiblesse qui s'associent pour
créer une dynamique positive
une farce voilà et
donc voilà c'est interprété par vincent
cassel et reda kateb émission à
retrouver en intégralité sur notre site
internet tv 78 points comme et sur notre
application mobile il se poursuit et
d'année en année ce week-end s'est
déroulé la 17e édition et d'arman
d'arman est le marché international
d'art contemporain rendez vous organisé
par le lions club de montigny le
bretonneux près de 50 artistes ont
présenté leurs oeuvres
retour avec manon varaldo pour la dix
septième édition d'armes année le marché
international d'art contemporain 47
artistes ont présenté leurs oeuvres
parmi eux isabelle masson cet artiste
peinte n'a pas fait d'école d'art elle
est autodidacte
j'aime l'univers un peu sur science
fiction et surtout j'aime les peintures
en mouvement donc j'aime l'art
contemporain aussi donc c'est pour ça
que mes oeuvres elles se sont organisées
autour des villes modernes et des
planètes qui bouge
cet article auquel est déjà venue lors
de précédentes éditions c'est une
première pour d'autres venus de plus
loin
30% d'artistes locaux on a aussi cette
année donc 30% de nouveaux artistes qui
se sont fait connaître par le bouche à
oreille est également particulièrement
cette année on a deux artistes écossais
qui sont dues au travers du comité de
jumelage de guyancourt
c'est la nouveauté de ce salon stuart
harper agent est venu faire la promotion
de deux artistes seco c'est ce soir que
ça palpite sur le petit score
ses oeuvres ont été réalisés par peter
scott
il a peint dans sa région d'enfance qui
est dans le nord de la côte à perdre in
ce sont des paysages de son enfance il
séjourné là bas avec sa famille pendant
les vacances c'est son enfance qu'il a
reproduit à travers ses tableaux à un
aspect personnel mais aussi historique
de l'appareil
un rendez vous où les fonds récoltés
vont à des associations
nous avons remis harman et un chèque de
2000 euros qui correspondait en veut aux
revenus de la de l'année dernière donc
c'était surtout sur la maltraitance
le lion ce club soutient également deux
autres causes le handicap et alzheimer
depuis 2014 cet artiste soutien c'est
cause en participant à arman et elle
travaille le plastique et le carton avec
des techniques différentes
je trouve que c'est très important de
pouvoir faire quelque chose d'être à la
fois que l'art soit d'utilité publique
pour la future édition harman et espère
s'ouvrir encore à l'international mille
visiteurs ont déambulé dans les allées
du salon durant le week end
et puis j'accueille en plateau
christelle groulx en bon soir dans ça
vous êtes la présidente de da doo ron
ron c'est une association vous organisé
ce vendredi la troisième édition du
trail au wynn aux clayes-sous-bois
mélange de course et aussi de
célébrations d'halloween en sera au
lendemain d'halloween justement quelles
sont les origines de la course
vous l'avez lancé il ya deux ans
pourquoi la halle a lancé voilà alors là
c'est la troisième édition
et puis je me suis retrouvé un petit peu
par hasard
organiser le grand prix des clés qui est
une course très anciennes sur la commune
alors je me suis dit quitte à à chercher
des sponsors et bien autant en profiter
pour proposer aux coureurs une deuxième
course pour compléter l'éventail des
courses proposées sur la ville mais
l'originalité c'est qu'on peut faire
cette course déguisée en tout cas les
participants on a pu le voir dans les
précédentes éditions viennent déguisés
tout à fait il ya même un podium pour
les trois plus beaux déguisements enfin
beau entre guillemets ça c'est halloween
et qu'on récompense d'ailleurs et donc
je remercie aussi les partenaires j'en
profite parce que c'est ce sont eux qui
nous proposent les cadeaux en grande
partie et quelques coureurs ni les
cadeaux pour les podiums donc là ça sera
la troisième édition quel bilan vous
vous tirez après les deux premières et
des choses que c'est une course qui
grandissent qu'il ya davantage de
participants qui viennent oui tout à
fait c'est une course qui grandit bien
la première fois
la première année on avait quatre cent
vingt classes et la deuxième année on en
a fait 500 et là on est d après ce que
450 préinscrits donc je pense qu'avec
les inscriptions sur place qui auront
lieu demain et après-demain au nez sean
et le vendredi matin avant la course je
précise que les inscriptions ils sont
d'ores et déjà terminée on peut
s'inscrire à one nation paris le centre
commercial des quais aux
clayes-sous-bois qu'est votre portable
oui une échelle paris est le partenaire
principal pour cette course là mais j'en
ai d'autres aussi j'ai super u de
fontenay le fleury enfin je vais pas
tous les citer mais il ya plein de
partenaires et puis
la même communauté enfin la part dans la
mairie des clayes-sous-bois qui me
soutient on prétend le site bien entendu
c'est indispensable
un événement festif sportif aussi
solidaire chaque année l'événement
soutient une association et les
reversent une partie de la recette comme
la dernière édition c'était une c'est un
soutien cette année à imagine fort
margot c'est ça tout à fait j'ai un ami
qui m'a qui m'a présenté cette
association là qui m'a beaucoup touché
eux-mêmes organise une course mois de
septembre
on parle de saint cloud la course des
enfants sans cancer et c'est vraiment
une très très belle course un bel
événement et puis du coup je me suis
sentie proche d'eux et j'étais
sensibiliser à leur cause donc je me
suis engagé à reverser un euro par par
coureur à cette association là qui
luttent pour les cancers pédiatriques
voilà tout à fait et c'est important
pour vous cet oncle solidaire c'est
important de la porter à cette course ça
donne un sens ça donne un sens à la
course
on sait pourquoi on organise c'est
vraiment pour moi c'est vraiment un plus
qui est très très important et on
précise que imagine fort maingot est
partie du combat de la jeune margaux ans
qui est décédé aujourd'hui et qui avait
lancé à l'époque de son vivant eu une
collecte pour récolter des fonds aussi
pour les enfants malades
les derrière vous aviez récolté 546
euros est ce qui est un objectif d'ores
et déjà pour cette année est le plus
possible et qu'il ya un mur no 6 pour
les personnes qui souhaitent faire un
don
donc n'hésitez pas lors de votre
inscription du retrait des dossards à
venir faire un don il y aura patricia
blanc la présidente de l'association qui
viendra aussi sur le site de la course
donc j'aurai grand plaisir à
l'accueillir et
et à lui remettre le chèque à l'issue de
la course alors le côté sportif pour
terminer cet entretien le parcours il
est 100% forêt pourquoi c'est important
il ya des trail qui propose des parcours
en urbain pourquoi vous c'est important
le 100% forêt d'abord parce que j'adore
ça et puis on avait un on est à une
cinquantaine de bénévoles quand même
autour de cet événement là et je les
remercie encore parce que sans eux c'est
impossible d'organiser quoi que ce soit
et la forêt c'est déjà le trail c'est
très à la mode maintenant et puis on
organisait des jeunes course sur route
donc on a vraiment souhaité profiter de
la forêt qui est vraiment pied du faux
il n'ya pas plus près 1 vous passez
larcher vous êtes en forêt dans quels
sont les différents parcours plus de 10
km 1 19 qui bon bah c'est la surprise me
fera 20 le 19 km parce qu'on a toujours
des contraintes liées le n 9 qui
des contraintes de parcours dans le
dernier moment et puis le 10 km marche
aussi donc il ya de la beauce il ya du
dénivelé et c'est stéphane qui nous a
fait un beau parcours encore cette année
je le remercie y en a pour tous les
goûts qu'on soit débutant ou l'allemand
tout à fait le 10 km l'an dernier avait
pris il avait gagné en un petit peu
moins de 40 minutes 39 minutes et donc
c'est vraiment très très bien sûr pour
un 10 km qui n'est pas plat mais
le 19 km avait été pliée en 1h 5 et le
10 km marche en 1h15 donc c'est vraiment
enfin on a des beaux chronos mais pour
tous les goûts fall et ceux qui courent
vite et ceux qui pour moins vite sont
les bienvenus bien entendu et ce trailer
in je le rappelle c'est ce vendredi
départ à 9 heures depuis le parc jean
carillon clayes sous bois et pour les
inscriptions elles sont d'ores et déjà
fermés clause sur internet mais vous
pouvez vous inscrire sur le site de one
nation à paris toutes les informations à
retrouver sur le site internet qui
s'affiche merci christelle grand merci à
vous présidente de l'association da doo
ron ron qui organise donc ce trail au
wynn une dernière information avant de
vous laisser qu'on a on a appris en fin
d'après-midi versailles partira du côté
de la réunion pour le 7e tour de la
coupe de france de football le tirage au
sort a livré son verdict les yvelinois
iront affronter sainte marienne club de
régionale une une division en dessous
donc des versaillais match le dimanche
17 novembre à 15h au 6e tour dimanche
dernier pour rappel le fcv a disposé est
de viry-châtillon au terme d'une séance
de tirs au but
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
non